The best bloopers are the simple bloopers:
the ones where talented, glamorous movie stars
are supposed to be in character…and then
they burst into laughter.
Maybe they flubbed a line, maybe they forgot
the line entirely, or maybe there's no reason
at all, and they just come down with a case
of the giggles.
Here are a few actors who started laughing
during their scenes, and just couldn't stop.
Eva Mendes - The Other Guys
Will Ferrell keeps it pretty loose when filming
the silliest of his silly comedies.
The Other Guys was directed by his longtime
writing partner Adam McKay, and both have
an extensive improv background, which means
Ferrell is strongly encouraged to riff while
filming.
Unfortunately for his co-stars, they never
know quite what he's going to say or do, which
makes it very tough to keep their composure
and stay in character …
"I had to go to a specialist to get my hips
realigned."
"The doctor said it was similar to, uh, operating
on a German Shepard when they have, uh, hip
dysplasia."
"I can't do this right now!"
Brad Pitt - Moneyball
It's a serious, compelling movie that's surprisingly
riveting given it's mostly about a bunch of
people talking about baseball and doing math
to figure out which baseball players are the
best investments.
But all that dry office and locker room chatter
evidently made Brad Pitt go a little bit batty
on the set of Moneyball ...
"Now he's gonna do what's never been done."
"Now he's gonna do what he's never done.
He's gonna round first, he's gonna take the
turn …"
Jimmy Fallon - Fever Pitch
He starred on Saturday Night Live for six
years and amassed an impressive legacy of
recurring characters and hilarious bits, but
Jimmy Fallon's probably best remembered for
his inability to keep a straight face through
sketches.
When Fallon graduated from SNL into movies
in the 2000s, he couldn't drop his habit,
and apparently laughed a lot while shooting
the baseball comedy Fever Pitch ...
"Frankly, most of the men I've dated have
been poodles."
"I can't do it."
Paul Rudd and Leslie Mann - This is 40
Melissa McCarthy was a delightful surprise
in This is 40.
She's a force of comic energy as she just
goes off on Rudd and Mann's characters, levying
a litany of hilarious improvised threats,
insults, and observations.
McCarthy never cracks, but Rudd and Mann however,
can't control themselves ...
"And I'm glad your husband died.
Because you're a f----ing a--hole.
He probably killed himself."
Jonah Hill - This is the End
The end-of-the-world comedy This is the End
stars a bunch of Hollywood's top young actors
playing fictionalized versions of themselves.
It's a crew of gifted comic performers with
agile improv comedy skills, including Jonah
Hill.
A few mean-spirited lines Hill improvised
about co-star Michael Cera were so ridiculous
he couldn't keep a straight face ...
"Yeah, he goes and puts on the dress, and
like, like, he's weird, he competes in those
pageants and shit."
"Wait.
So he …"
"Yeah, he pretends to be a kid …"
"Dude never met a condom."
"You're f---ing with me."
"For real, dude, honestly, he probably has
some s---.
I know he has AIDS, actually."
"What?!"
Johnny Depp - Pirates of the Caribbean
Getting paid millions to dress up like a pirate?
That's just life for Johnny Depp, who has
starred as Captain Jack Sparrow in multiple
Pirates of the Caribbean blockbusters.
He's clearly delighted to get to play a high-seas
buccaneer—because he has such a good time
he just can't quit laughing on the set ...
"You knew this."
"I did not."
"I did not!"
"Not for me.
For my father."
"It's gonna be okay.
We're gonna keep going."
"Cut it!"
Margot Robbie - Suicide Squad
There was a lot to laugh at during the filming
of Suicide Squad.
It's one of the most over-the-top comic book
movies ever made, with multiple over-the-top
villains in over-the-top costumes with over-the-top
personalities vying for screen time.
Margot Robbie played Harley Quinn, a protégé
of the Joker, and Robbie, befitting the character,
was quick to laugh on set...
"Jesus!"
"Sorry."
"If I could see my actual reflection, it would
have …"
Mila Kunis - Bad Moms
The cast of this 2016 comedy was stacked with
hilarious people, and star Mila Kunis is no
slouch either, with eight years of That '70s
Show on her resume.
The laughter flowed fast and furious for Kunis
while making the ensemble comedy — it didn't
take much for her to get the giggles …
"I've been watching Extra.
You gotta check out Brad Pitt's new haircut.
Tight."
"This chicken sucks."
"Then don't eat it."
"I'll eat it.
Give it to me.
It's fine."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!